hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israel hallo ich bin auch gebrauchte
murat ist auch mit dabei
heute gibt das zweite video von unserer
usa-reise im ersten video haben wir euch
schon ein paar eindrücke und einblicke
gegeben
wie es dort war und heute soll das rad
weiter gesprochen werden und heute
erzählen wir euch ein bisschen mehr
davon und zwar hatten wir ja die firma
kitchenaid angefragt ob wir denn nicht
die möglichkeit bekämen oder bekommen
könnten dort zu filmen und sie haben uns
das erlaubt und wir sind das erste auch
deutsch-türkische schwierige chemische
kammer und badische kamera themen er was
dort überhaupt filmen durfte und was
mich natürlich sehr gefreut hat und ich
war total aufgeregt aber den ersten teil
hab die wie gesagt schon gesehen
und heute soll es darum gehen euch nur
ein bisschen mehr davon zu erzählen
wir waren ja untergebracht in dayton und
zwar ist es etwa eine flugstunde von
chicago entfernt und kitsch made
befindet sich ja in greenville und
greenwheel ist ein richtig kleines dorf
und deswegen kommt mir da gar nicht
untergebracht werden was da gar kein
hotel gibt deswegen waren wir in dayton
und dayton ist eigentlich in us
verhältnissen auch nicht so wirklich
groß also weiter nur 750 1000 einwohner
als 100.000 mehr als stuttgart
ungefährdet
für mich ist es ja schon eine mega
metropole gehört ja aber für israel ist
wie gesagt sehr klein und wir waren dort
untergebracht
das war auch so eine empfehlung von
kitchenaid wir kennen doch nicht aus
wallonien usa und weiß nicht in welchem
hotel ich gehen soll
also haben wir in dayton im hotel
ausgesucht weil da eben auch direkt der
flughafen war und eben alles gut zu
erreichen war
das hotel lag ziemlich im
industriegebiet
das war deswegen haben wir von der stadt
treten und von den einwohnern dort
eigentlich gar nichts gesehen und sind
am ersten tag im hotel auch angekommen
das war dann nachmittags so etwa 16 uhr
und deutscher zeit werden aber schon
mitten in der nacht gewesen das heißt
wir waren alle übermüdet hundemüde sind
im hotel angekommen haben eingecheckt
und ich habe erst mal die kinder
schlafen gelegt denn die hatten wirklich
einen tag hinter sich und die haben auch
sofort geschlafen und wir anderen wir
haben uns dann auf den weg gemacht und
wollten einfach ein bisschen die
umgebung erkunden
wir waren einfach überdreht und wollten
wirklich total die zeit auch ausnutzen
und das wirklich einfach mal ja du
kannst ja nicht schlafen wenn es in
amerika und genau da wird aussehen und
wo sind nur die indianer und kaum
und es war eigentlich schade dass das
hotel im industriegebiet war ich jedoch
gern ein bisschen was von der stadt
gesehen aber andererseits konnten wir da
eben auch ein paar eindrücke sammeln
wir hatten da zum beispiel diese ganzen
fast-food-ketten direkt vom hotel also
da war nämlich alle da ja wirklich alle
und es gab kein einziges restaurant was
irgendwie der wunderschöne crackberry
crack akku burger king mcdonalds alles
alles alles also marta
ich habe mir gleich mal ist wasser holen
müssen und bin dann rüber in borna das
ist praktisch der globus von den usa
wahrscheinlich also ein riesen zu
vermarkten und darwin hatte ich erst mal
gleich in den bug abteilung gestürmt und
wollten mal gucken wie die back
abteilung aussieht und also zwar ein
riesen riesengeschäft aber ich muss
sagen von der bak abteilung reich sehr
enttäuscht weil ja es gab gar nicht so
viel ich denke die sich in silber
streusel in allen möglichen farben und
es gab es gar nicht diese mit nicht ganz
ganz anders als wir das heißt er alles
diese riesen verpackung weil es ist
alles in kanistern drin wenn die
apfelschorle woods hole mir dann holen
die sich gleich dingen reden die ganze
wahrheit kongress liter apfelschorle und
wenn wir dort cool fand das heißt cool
ja eigentlich schon foul
also da gab es eine vorgefertigte
obstteller mit dips da ich mir die leben
ja doch ein bisschen gesund aber er hat
alles hat diese fertigen gemüse sie war
alles viel leichter und sogar in der wir
hatten sogar im hotel war sogar die
mikrowelle im hotel
also das ist ja mehr essen wirklich sehr
sehr viel fertiges zeug und in
riesenmengen also dann haben die was uns
auch aufgefallen
ich habe mich gleich mal muss dazu sagen
ich habe gleich mal wasser geholt und so
ein paar typische amerikanische sachen
ich habe zum beispiel auch diese
getrockneten bohnen mal mitgenommen und
die karotten und habe mich da mal
eingedeckt gar nicht gegessen
die oreo kekse muss sagen sie haben
wirklich
also verschiedene sachen es ist wahnsinn
was für eine auswahl hat ja aber wenn
das alles anschaust es war alles so dass
ich nur schade fand die ganzen
plastiktüten überall ja und und die vor
allem was auch noch hatten also aus ist
uns krise so gemerkt diese riesen autos
ja ja ja es ist so da brauchst du eine
lkw in deutschland und die verbrauchen
und haufen ich glaube das auto was der
gefahren ist hat 28 nicht aber dass auch
verbraucht und wenn sie mal ist die
machen ist auch noch gar nicht aus alle
müssen überlegen unsere autos haben wir
inzwischen viele eine
start-stopp-automatik das wäre mir diese
eine minute eine ampel stehen dass die
autos ausgenommen weniger sprit und
emissionen haben verbrauchen und bei
ging es so wenn ihnen supermarkt
einkaufen gehen dann lassen die motoren
laufen ja ich muss dazu sagen dass sprit
war auch im vergleich zu unserem
risikoausgleich keine ausrede also ich
denke dass jogi hat einfach nicht so ist
doch alles in gallonen die haben wir
ganz andere mistwetter ich verstehe
absolut nicht aber unsere messwerte
saloppe sieben videos sind glaubt eine
gallone und einige als 3,7 liter haben
ungefähr in euro gekostet also ein
drittel von uns darin spricht ja also
ich der wahnsinn
aber es gibt natürlich auch ganz viel
positives ich bin dann wie gesagt von
dem format wieder ins hotel gekommen da
hat murat also wir haben uns halt eben
immer abwechseln müssen wir gegen
kindern die jungs der turm der frank und
daniel die sind über in
in suters hinzu gut aus weil sie kennst
aus den filmen auseinander
ich kannte es nicht und james kelly sagt
auf dem rad bescheid wir sind im hud
hast und ich gehe dann zum rad und helm
bora die jungs ziehen im hooters geht
doch auch über von der moral
jetzt werden ein lachendes gut dass das
ist so oder so ein franchise lerne war
so eine sportsbar unterlaufen die damen
etwas leicht bekleidet sind nicht nur so
entsprungen war jemals tank tops an und
kurze schauer jungs haben das geht
dorthin wo viel trinken und dann dass
einem fast food restaurant gegangen wie
die jungs waren eine stunde glaubt ja
und dann kam die andrea ziehe ich glaube
die weiß nicht was das ist sehr
geschickt und da noch nicht einmal die
weiß echt nicht mehr ist da nicht bis
die andrea zu mir ins zimmer kam nahm at
getrunken und dann sagt sie und hält
jung sie sind daher gut das habe ich
auch fotos gemacht mit hey warum fotos
und dann sagt sie gegen den frauen dort
und dann habe ich mal gegoogelt und dann
wusste ich wo sie sind nach hause kohle
sagt sie aber
aber ich weiter am nächsten tag auch
dort zwar ziemlich lustig und ich muss
sagen was man vielleicht voraussagen
kann
da saßen wir am nächsten tag nämlich
draußen auch einfach so abend nach dem
essen marl und essen draußen auf der
terrasse und das ist eben diese ganzen
wenn dieser tod ventilatoren und es ist
einfach du sitzt da und weit und breit
ist keine im industriegebiet und zwar
wunderschön wirklich wunderschön
der service ist natürlich ein star muss
nur sagen in ganz amerika wirklich toll
da kann man sich eine scheibe
abschneiden
das essen muss ich ehrlich sagen war
furchtbar wirklich angst und leid ich
fand es essen wirklich furchtbar
klar es gibt im leben nur wenn man gut
essen haben ja damals gut gegessen
das sorgte für richtig bezahlt ich würde
mal sagen wir fahren mit unserer reise
fort und unsere reise am nächsten tag
beginnt im hotel
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute bin ich wieder auf tour
wie ihr wisst bin ich gerade mit meiner
familie und mit meinem team in amerika
und um genau zu sein sind wir gerade in
dayton das ist in ohio
ungefähr eine stunde flugzeit von
chicago entfernt und wissen jetzt hier
weil wir heute eine firmenbesichtigung
bei kitchenaid machen werden kitchenaid
ist es nicht hier in dayton sondern in
greenville das ist eine stunde autofahrt
von her aber das ist ein ganz kleines
süßes dorf deswegen gibt es
wahrscheinlich auch gar kein hotel
bleiben kann
deswegen sie mir zu entdecken und fahre
jetzt gleich los und werden dort
kitchenette anschauen
vor allem wenn ich jetzt echt schon
richtig gespannt darauf und freue mich
schon darauf was uns dort erwartet
deswegen gehen jetzt direkt los und wir
nehmen euch alle mit
m
die sicherheitsbeauftragte max mit rein
aber statt sie dürfen keine kinder mit
rein
ich will jetzt hier drinnen wird schon
startklar für die führung gleich in der
fabrik hat schon meine kleidung bereit
und hier draußen ist noch ein kleiner
eingangsbereich auch für die besucher
und so eine kleine übersicht über die
geschichte der kitchenaid also alles hat
angefangen im jahr 1908 da wurde die
erste kitchenaid zusammengestellt zwar
nicht für den hausgebrauch sondern für
den gewerblichen bereich also würden
bäckerei zum beispiel und 1919 war dass
hier die erste maschine im privaten
haushalt und die hat sich natürlich im
laufe der zeit auch verändert und der
küche angepasst hier sehen wir zum
beispiel das modell von 1927
da erkennt man schon so ein bisschen die
form sowie die kitchenaid heute aussieht
und im prinzip haben wir hier das modell
von 1962 und die sieht ja eigentlich
fast so aus wie die kitchenaid es sind
die ich zu hause ab 1999 wurde übrigens
die einmillionste kitchenaid atem
hergestellt das ist diese hier diese
goldene spezial edition und die kit
heißt übrigens in das kommt aus dem
lateinischen und heißt handwerk und zwar
deswegen weil an der maschine so viel
von hand gearbeitet wird aber ich glaube
das schauen wir unseren besten jetzt
drinnen an und gehen gleich mal an die
erste station
hier bin ich jetzt vom ersten teil der
produkte
bei der lackierung
jetzt hier schon hängen werden um
anderen
und
viele verschiedene gibt's nicht für
jeden
und jetzt fallen die ganz
der roboter der distanz
ist wieder da
hier bereich gleich durch
teile vom jetzt hier herunter
hier drauf
red
bereit
heile dich anbieter
wir haben
den arbeiter an einer produkte
das auch stündlich verkehren
die ganze strecke
liefern
ganz oben
unter wasser
die mitarbeiter hier hat natürlich
ein
die anderen
doch angesteckt
ja
die produktion war jetzt drüben im
gebäude und im gebäude hinter mir ist
der komplette versand das heißt alle
maschinen die produziert werden kommen
hier kurz rein werden gelagert und von
hier dann in die ganze welt verschickt
kommt einfach mal mit
ich bin jetzt hier im lager viele
kartons und vergibt im lager über 75.000
palettenstellplätze also man kann sich
ausrechnen wie viele maschinen hier sind
und jede
egal wo auf der welt
und hier zu sein das ist auch mein base
die vor drei jahren gekauft aber jedem
lager und wo das
nach deutschland gesendet ist wahnsinn
hier im boden sind übrigens
metallschienen drin die sind jetzt unten
drin das sieht man nicht und passt auf
dass dafür dass der stapler da kommt
dann hierher und loggt sich praktisch
ein also wieso magnet und kann dann
eigentlich noch vor und zurück fahren
und neben den staffel hoch und
runterfahren und zwar dafür dass er eben
nicht aus was irgendwie in der palette
reinfährt also da kann wirklich gar
nichts passieren ist alles absolut
sicher
nachdem wir dann in greenville die
produktion der kitt maschinen gesehen
haben sind wir noch nach krümmel in die
stadt rein gefahren und es ist wie schon
gesagt eine richtig kleine zuckersüße
staat eigentlich schon fast ein dorf
also will ich so viel wie für mich so
mein traum dort richtig schön die
straßen die häuser die latte
wunderschön und da sind wir in den
kitchenette experience shop reingegangen
und haben da die liebe gloria
kennengelernt und die claudia ist so ich
glaube so stellt man sich eine typische
amerikanische mutter vor
die hat uns gleich herzlich begrüßt und
uns auch ein bisschen butter hat muss
ich sagen es gab selbst gebackene kekse
die hat sie uns dann aus dem
tiefkühlfach rausgeholt und es rückt
alles agenten frei und es roch nach
apple nach cookies und es war wirklich
so toll ich glaube wir waren auch zwei
stunden da obwohl es gar nicht so viel
zu sehen gab klar es gab ganz viel von
kitchenaid und ganz viele produkte auch
aber wir haben uns er dann die ganze
zeit mit der glaube ja unterhalten wir
uns gleich ein paar schürzen mit gegeben
und so keine taschen und er ist wirklich
super cool dort und es hat auch erzählt
dass er da ich glaube jede woche auch in
dieser großen küche
diese workshops gibt und einfach kurse
macht mit ihren besuchern die da leben
kommen
und hätten wir mehr zeit gehabt wäre ich
gerne dort geblieben und hätte einfach
mal so einen bug oder kochkurs mit ihr
zusammen gemacht
ich denke das ist doch super du hast mir
viel zu teuer war wie sehr aber ich sage
noch mal drüber nach apples ja das waren
super lecker und wir haben auch so
einige probierten elektro stecke oder
einschlägt war das hat er gemacht habe
das war nur so ist es ja was war
wirklich super schön dort und es gibt
noch erzählen zu ihrem kleinen shop der
die wir haben werden die ersten
deutschen die sie jemals gesehen hat ja
das stimmt ja hat so ach gott hat uns
eine e-mail gezeigt von einer von einer
deutschen kundin die irgendwie
die maschine gekauft hatte ein problem
und ein problem hatte und es kam dann am
ende bei ihr alle in greenville heißt es
übersetzt
wie lange es dann er übersetzt und dann
hat sie sich darum gekümmert was
weitergegeben an kitchenaid und weil es
sonst hat mir viele sachen die wir in
deutschland nicht haben ja natürlich
aber es war einfach genial ja und
backofen handschuhe und war wirklich
super schön also dem dayton in
greenville welt wirklich gerne noch ein
bisschen geblieben hätten wir ja leider
waren wir noch essen gewesen
in greenville aber das erstens gab es
nicht richtig ist und dann viel zu wenig
zeit
wenn ihr den usa geht wirklich dann
nehmt euch monat zeit ansonsten
abgeschlagen ein ganzes jahr
alle
falls ihr mal ganz doof wenn ich in
greenville seid dann gibt's hier nicht
nur die fabrik von kitchenaid sondern
gibt es auch einen kitchenaid experience
shop und war ist er in towntown also im
stadtzentrum von green mill
und es ist wirklich ein ganz
schnuckeliger laden und hier kann man im
prinzip alles kaufen was ist von
kitchenaid gibt also nicht nur die mixa
und die küchenmaschine an sich sondern
wirkt sich auch ganz viel zubehör
toll jetzt eine küche und habe keine
schürze mit dabei und kein globus
jetzt kann ich die küche in der benutzen
also sagen sie sich die perfekte
amerikanische kueche echt cool durch das
man entweder wahnsinn da passt zu der
einkauf für eine amerikanische familie
vielleicht für ein tag
das ist mein mann extrakt oder hast ein
lied
das war unser erster tag in der
produktion von kitchenaid und in
greenville und es waren wirklich super
einblicke wahnsinn
also wirklich wirklich wunderschön und
im nächsten video werden wir wieder in
die fabrik gehen und zwar gibt es da ja
eine kleine neuigkeit von der uns schon
erzählt wurde
und wir werden uns morgen noch mit der
lieben ja ne treffen
sie hat uns übrigens auch eingeladen in
die usa und wir haben auch vorab schon
ein paar mal miteinander geschrieben und
sie begleitet uns auch auf dieser reise
und mit ihr werden wir morgen ein
bisschen sprechen und dann nochmal die
kitchenaid fabrik anschauen
genau da gibt es neuheiten und mini
neuheit genau einer mini neuheit gibt
schauen wir uns morgen an also im
nächsten video ich hoffe auf jeden fall
ich bin so toll wenn die zuschauer mal
reinschauen können wie sowas hergestellt
wir haben euch schon in mehreren filmen
schon mal mitgenommen in frankreich die
wahlen gehen sieht man einfach mal was
dahinter steckt und wie viel arbeit
dahinter steckt und ich finds halt echt
cool dass sie den usa hergestellt werden
ich sag die lohnkosten sind zwar hoch
aber es wird trotzdem dort hergestellt
aber seht ihr am morgen genau das sehen
wir morgen noch mal also bis morgen